U.S officials believe an explosion from
a bomb or some sort of sabotage downed
the private jet carrying Wagner group
chief yevgeni pagosian on Wednesday
though they cautioned assessments for
preliminary and incomplete
The Wall Street Journal had three
Aviation experts with combined Decades
of experience analyzing plane crashes
review the footage though they said it's
hard to be certain without access to
physical evidence at the crash site they
too saw no signs that the plane was shot
down and said initial evidence suggests
the crash was probably caused by an
in-flight catastrophic failure possibly
due to a bomb or sabotage here's why
first the plume of smoke around the
plane seems to be the remnants of an
internal explosion
a missile strike would create long
tracks of smoke from the missiles
approach none are seen here
Additionally the Jet and Embraer Legacy
600 has no history of in-flight
structural or mechanical failure
the plane also appears mostly intact in
its fall with only one of the Wings
missing
a strike from a missile capable of
reaching more than twenty thousand feet
would have broken the plane apart more
the white substance trailing the plane
is another clue it was an internal
explosion it's not smoke but rather the
plane's fuel spraying into the air from
ruptured fuel lines
a missile would have likely ignited the
leaking fuel resulting in black smoke
the way the plane Falls also points
toward an internal explosion it's
fluttering to the ground without control
a possible indication that the explosion
happened near the Tail of the plane
the somewhat contained wreckage pattern
further supports an internal explosion
in one place we can see the main body of
the plane while in another area a mile
away we see the tail
a missile would have scattered shrapnel
and debris more widely
[Music]
the leaking fuel appears to have ignited
when the plane's main body crashed
parts of the wreckage are covered in
small dents according to the experts
these are normal markings from Impact
and probably not missile shrapnel
the markings are caused by bolted
sections tearing apart and broken off
pieces of the plane hitting other parts
of the aircraft
all of this supports preliminary
assessments from U.S intelligence which
say pregosian was killed in an
assassination plot